and what a daunting task for tooky
toussaint tonight as he makes his season
debut
against a team that's number one and
hits in the national league
so as i said a daunting task when you're
making your first start in the big
leagues of the season tooky and his
career in the big leagues with the
braves six and three
but a very high era just under six he
has faced the padres before that was
quite a while ago and it was only for an
inning or so
in relief
and on the ground freddie freeman will
handle grisham with ease and that's how
our game starts
and took he blew him away
96 inside corner three pitches and tatis
is retired missed his location a little
bit but still blew it by tatis
sharply hit but into the shift and riley
is going to take care of cronenworth
tukey welcome back to the show on the
bow tonight for the san diego padres is
you darvish 34 year old veteran 19th
start
first start of the second half
fifth of his career against these braves
and uh he's still searching for that
first career victory against the atlanta
braves and there you see the numbers
runner at first base in peterson
and a swing of the miss and he strikes
out swanson first k of the night for you
darvish or the slider
popped up
shallow left field fam wanders in and
under and makes the catch that ends the
first inning done with one from atlanta
without a score
and almonte looking to raise that 223
batting average
hammered into the right field corner
that's going to get down for extra bases
almante flies around first he's on his
way to second he'll stand there
with a two-out double
hammered left field that's down for a
base hit tommy fan comes up around third
almante throw to the plate cut off into
second safely it's one nothing in
atlanta heredia jumps on the first pitch
yeah as good as he's been with two
strikes not so good on the first pitch
of an at-bat and for a team like the
braves that loves to swing at the first
pitch
the braves won that battle there
good base running by heredia two to go
on the to go on the throw to second base
get into scoring position
picked at third by machado up and
throwing in plenty of time
nice play by manny machado down there at
third base for out number two
swanson spins on this one and the short
hop hit so hard plenty of time to spin
and throw
it's worth another look that's one of
those in between hops that is not an
easy play
but guess who makes it look easy
commander machado
so machado will stand in with a runner
on first one away padres down one
nothing in the top of the fourth freddy
freeman and jay cronenworth over at
first base this one is lying down the
left field line and it's going to be a
fair ball
right up against the wall as cronenworth
will get to third base to second with a
double goes manny machado
second and third with one out
[Applause]
fly ball left field elmonte will make
the catch tagging it third is
chronoworth here comes the throw it is
cut off and the padres have tied the
game
sack five for tommy pham ties it up one
to one
he has struck out tatis and got him to
pop up yeah i like that right there
tatis has been aggressive
and that's hammered to third reilly
handles a sinking line drive that tati
smoked
yeah see freddie's numbers since june
the first phenomenal across the board
second in the national league with 53
hits since june the first set down 11 of
the last 12. as freddie hits one a mile
high toward left fam going back at 375.
he's not gonna get it freddie freeman
goes opposite field and the braves take
the lead
like darvish went with the fastball
there and
didn't get it where he wanted it outside
corner but thigh-high instead of
knee-high
and left-handed hitters like that pitch
up over there
then you start slipping sliding that's
not good bad things can happen then
where's you trying to
using the pitcher's plate trying to get
that mud off of his cleats
and then it just builds right back up
again once you step on the dirt
there's the tongue depressor there you
go yep
that will help yeah i was always taught
use your other hand you don't want to
slip and cut your throwing hand
falsio marquez the opening empire coming
out look at that that's a mess that's
quite a bit it has gathered
and you know when you're pitching right
and you you drive towards home plate and
you stride just a little bit of slip man
you can get hurt
we've got a close game here so it's it's
crunch time for the bullpen now as
darvish exits
nice that is strike three nicely done by
tim hill and tim hill out of the bullpen
doing work once again as he strands a
couple of inherited runners let's see if
tyler matsuk can take care of jericks
and profar
the padres have a two-out rally here
back-to-back singles you got to be
careful here
fly ball shallow center heredia says
he's got it and he does
san diego strands two it's time for the
stretch
now machado behind in the count
with the padres down a run it's a 2-1
braves lead we're in the eighth
high fly ball right center heredia going
back to the warning track the park will
hold it
chris martin keeps the braves in front
three defenders between second base and
third base yeah like i said it would
stand to reason that they're going to
pound them in with sliders and fastballs
but
we'll see
on the ground who wants it ozzie
backhand fires in the braves winner
this was a major league ballgame
great timely hitting from that man
freddie freeman
but for me tom the story of the night
was the start of tooky toussaint against
one of the hottest offenses in the world